hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today is the finale of our month-long
shindig that we've been a part of for a
bit and today's event is going to be the
soon dot event these on whose gambit as
are gonna be going over what's in the
remake of this event and then talking
about what didn't make it into the
remake and stayed in the original from
last year so it's like the V if you do
enjoy subscriber free new I covered the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes that here
updates the Patchett's and the leaks I
thought if we kept it today with
everything happening the world of
foreigner I never miss out on an update
don't be say subscribe to the channel
and with that let's get started with
today's video
so first up as always is going to be the
lootable stuff that made it into the
event the first is going to be the
effect the galilei's ultimate of course
this is available in Idol execution and
emote form if you just want to get them
all separately you're gonna have to
grind constantly as they don't come in a
bundle they come in the three separate
forms and you've obviously watched my
past through video so I don't think I
need to repeat that part as I think you
guys get the point it's a nice effect
though and it's got this yin-yang symbol
at the bottom and I use it for an outfit
that usually has a black and white color
scheme to it so this could definitely
fit some characters there's also the
ornament galilei's keepsake of course
it's faction based meaning it's the same
general design but each faction has
their own small changes to make each one
unique and I believe the blue on that
you're seeing on screen changes
depending on the color of your original
outfit but don't quote me on that and
lastly is the lootable battle outfit the
galilei's warrior all these I just
mentioned are considered lootable so
after matches you will earn these at
random they could be for a totally
different hero that you don't even play
that's just usually how these go next is
the purchasable stuff and that is first
up is the two illustrious outfits the
chieng emissary in the Sun das gambit
who's supposed to be discounted at
thirteen thousand steal but after the
week they will go back up to twenty K
and these will obviously stay in the
game for the rest of its time the one
that won't stay for the rest of its time
is the emo and that is Zahn whose fire
which is seven thousand steal and once
the week is done it will disappear again
so you definitely want to get that
quickly if you want these of course are
only available through steel and that is
the only way to get them then of course
lastly are the weapons of course these
are lootable like the ornament battle
outfit and effect but these will drop
for the hero you play and won't be
random which is why I put them
separately at the end of this video
the weapons are a huge difference in the
past events as these obviously have a
very purple color scheme to it so paring
things like with the illustrious elf at
the e mode a purple weapon and a
character with a purple color scheme it
can really all fit nice together like I
have on my sundial
it's I'm actually a super big fan of the
Vikings this time around as I think
their weapons are personally some of my
favorite for this event there is
probably a huge chance that the weapons
are still going as I'm still talking so
in an effort to keep that going while I
speak I'm gonna be discussing the very
last part of the video which is what
didn't make it into the remake those
specific things that didn't make it to
the remake the first up always is going
to be the main menu in the minion
changes the minions actually had a lot
of ash on them to emphasize the story of
the whole like breach map being overrun
and [ __ ] was being blown up through fire
and stuff so that's why the all the
minions had ash on them they main menu
also had this really cool like moving
kind of image a lot of them have the
moving images but this kind of give me a
side-scroller vibe and it felt like it
just kept going and going and it
personally was my favorite picture for
that event and of course the game mode
is not returning sadly the game mode is
currently carousel afire which was the
original version of the week one of the
four on our games we're in week two that
became carousel of Ragnarok which was
the game mode last week this is now a
PvE game mode and a personal favorite of
mine you had to escort the commander
through waves of different enemies as
the place you were guarding was being
blown up destroyed and overrun they
needed to escape with the commander and
it was really really hard if your team
wasn't coordinated I personally wish
they brought this back because there was
a lot of game modes I really enjoyed
especially this one as it was a PvE and
the last one that we had gotten before
this one was the one from season 5 so it
was a very long time since we had a PvE
game mode and I wish that they can come
up with more so this is kind of a hope
that though we'll get some this year
yeah with that that's gonna be
everything that has to do with these on
whose gambit event as always guys like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new we are finally done with this
month-long stuff so if you did get bored
with this all kind of stuff going on I
totally understand hopefully next week I
don't think there's gonna be a whole lot
of info but I won't have a video going
up on Thursday just to keep you guys
occupied but a couple weeks after that
we should be getting the new season and
a lot of info on the new season maybe
new executions new character stuff I'm
super excited as we could finally talk
about the new hero and possibly who is
gonna be
what faction everything like that will
hopefully be coming up in the next
couple weeks as always stay tuned to the
channel but like I said like to be if
you do enjoy subscribe for new I covered
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the Patrick's and the leaks if
under we kept the stated with everything
happening then the world of foreigner I
never miss out when an update doubtfully
stay subscribe the channel and that take
care guys
I'll see you on the next video peace out
[Music]
you